un énorme coup de coeur pour blanche
gardin qui a explosé tous les scores
hier sur ces 8 avec son spectacle plus
d'un million de téléspectateurs elle
était leader quentinoise hors cette
filiale est subversive l ai cru sans
être particulièrement trash mois sauf
que c'est cru le vrai terme l os tout
dire
y compris d'ailleurs sur nous sur touche
pas à mon père aimait ça mais bien de
mon sac est marrant on est les premiers
à défoncer pays que les émissions si on
n'accepte pas qu'on défonce
d'ailleurs il plein d'articles oui alors
justement je voulais quand même le dire
parce qu'on a lu tout un tas d'articles
en disant vous les convois l'extrait
d'abord bas si vous voulez oui parce
qu'elle est drôle cette fille elle est
formidable d'accord c'est le perroquet
beinheim on va regarder un extrait et
vous allez vous dire pourquoi vous vous
êtes énervé
oui parce que c'est bizarre ce qui
cédera ses pouvoirs et à quelle heure un
merci c'est si nombreux c'est bien là
que j'ai aucune raison d'ailleurs de
vous remercie d'être si nombreux vous
avez aucun mérite à retirer
individuellement du fait que cette salle
soit pleine
bien sûr
mais c'est ça c'est la magie du
collectif en fait ainsi succèdent cyril
hanouna c'est ça aussi
dans ce cadre là on parle pas de magie
évidemment on nous parle plutôt de
malédiction mais c'est ça c'est un
problème quand même parce que j'ai mes
calculs de lots de gérance l'audimat ne
prend pas en compte le recul avec lequel
on regarde mais le problème c'est qu'on
s'aperçoit pas qu'on devient con c'est
ça c'est la tragédie d'existence reçu
plein d'amis qui sont de vue qu'on sans
s'en apercevoir
il ya plein de gens dont bruno masure
qui veut exister à chaque fois ils
exigent appuyé sur twitter que dans la
vie non mais c'est vrai bruno masure qui
dit regardez blanc le gardien sur ces
huit ça déménage le plus gros le début
de son show elle pulvérise plus que
méchamment à signer le nahd qui officie
sur la même chaîne
à mon avis personne à visionner bon nous
on t'aime beaucoup mais si on visionne
les spectacles ou visionnent
généralement ce qu'on achète un pas
franchement c'est comme quand tu achètes
un appart une visite avant voilà donc
vous mais alors justement il faut quand
même dire ces deux heures passées sur
canal+ également sur comédie donc
évidemment que tout le monde a vu ça
mais justement c'est l'humour moi
j'adore que nous avons on s'est fait
tamponner partout en disant à nice se
fait déchirer que cetera et cetera
il se fait déchirer par tous les
journalistes mais évidemment qu'on a vu
et qu'on est d'accord et que c'est de
l'humour ici c'est une émission d'humour
on à la dérision surnommé on fracasse
tout on se moque de moi le premier et
après on bravo à elle j'ai trouvé ça
très drôle
alors les pleins d'articles voilà de ce
genre mais bon voilà je vous le dis nous
on adore le spectacle et on était sûr
avec les dirigeants de ces huit qu'ils
allaient faire un carton assassin carton
au delà de nos espérances un joli
puisque 1 billion 120 de téléspectateurs
c'était loin devant même burger quiz 1
sur tmc est né à l'appel a tout
bouleversé oui alors moi j'adore blanche
gardin jeu de corps qu'elle a un talent
fou c'est au vitriol ces méchants ces
corps aux règles sévères crio nouvelles
à des proches
donc ça je me régale mais en revanche
derrière sortie mépris bobos moi je
pense que c'est plus subtil que ça c'est
à dire je pense qu'on peut adorer tpm
paix et adoré blanche gardin ne serait
donc on n'est pas des téléspectateurs
forcément décérébrés tu regardes tes pmp
on peut aimer tpm paix et aimer 28
minutes et mettez pmp et et mai dernier
livre de christine angot et je trouve
que tu
par exemple mais c'est mon cas par
exemple
oui eh bien écoutez vous est l'exception
qui confirme la règle et donc je trouve
que c'est parfois un petit peu plus
subtil un peu moins manichéen que ce
qu'elle veut bien dire exactement mais
bon à 115 kg adoré moitié alors elle m'a
envoyé un sms hier soir pour dire trop
le drôle blanche gardin ça va cartonner
j'en suis sûr ce que je vous jouez
envoie des sms à communiquer avec peu de
monde dans l'émission j'ai eu l'honneur
de vraiment dossier qu'en plus ce soir
vous êtes le seul à répondre puisque les
autres dorment à c'est tout oui j'ai un
ou deux journalistes médias mais de
mauvaises langues qui m'ont laissé
entendre que certaines personnes dans la
chaîne y compris vous avait souhaité
couper avait demandé au départ de couper
la séquence c'est vraiment un couple
sait encore mais des conneries pas
possible d'entendre des conneries
pareilles je suis sans mes cd qui échoue
et je vous dis vous avez entendu encore
des bêtises absolues
je vous le dis on adore le spectacle
sinon l'aurais pas acheté non mais
croyez qu'on est maso à l'exploit mais
s'ils voulaient couper beaucoup p
excusez moi non mais c'est vrai je l'aï
déjà dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]